I basically talk about is with a
function what you have is you know you
have an input and you have an output you
have an X which is generally associated
with the input and the Y which is
generally associated with the output the
domain which again is associated with
the ax the range which is associated
with the Y and then you have the
independent variable that's what you put
into the function and you have the
dependent variable that's what you have
coming out so basically you can think of
these as a group and these as a group I
just want you to understand that concept
so when we talk about inverse functions
what we're doing is we're actually
reversing that process so some examples
of inverse functions are like if you
multiply by two and then you divide by
two
you know you're you're reversing that
process if you add three and then you
subtract three you know you're reversing
that process if you square something and
then you take the square root those are
all examples of inverse functions but
the simplest example that your teacher
may give you in your classes you know
what's the inverse you know of this data
set here we can see the 3 is mapping to
1 right because the X as the input Y is
the output 4 is mapping to negative 2
etc but if you wanted to find the
inverse function what you would do is
you would interchange the inputs and the
outputs the XS and the Y's so we can
write the inverse as 1 3 negative 2 4 6
5 3 comma 7 so that's the idea you're
just interchanging the input and output
that's the most simplest example now a
little bit more challenging example say
for example they take us and they give
us this equation of a line y equals 2x
minus 1 and they say you know what's the
inverse of this equation well there's
two different ways to approach this one
way is like an intuitive way and I'll
explain that so when you put X in what
do you do you start with X then what do
you do you multiply by 2 so I'll write x
2 and then what you do then you subtract
1 so then you go to minus 1 all right so
I'm just kind of writing this out but if
you wanted to reverse this process you
would go instead of from left to right
you would go from right to left so
instead of subtracting 1 what would you
do you would add 1 okay and then instead
of multiplying by 2 you would divide by
2 like that so what we could do if we
want to write the inverse function we
could say well we'll start with X we're
gonna add 1
then we're gonna divide that quantity by
two and that's going to be our new
equation now we could write this a
little bit differently by splitting this
up into two fractions y equals one-half
X plus 1/2 that's the intuitive way to
do it the thing about reversing out
those steps but the algebraic way of
doing it is to just interchange the X
and the y solve for the new Y so what
we're gonna do is we're gonna review see
why you're gonna put X wherever you see
X you're gonna put Y and then what we're
gonna do is we're gonna solve for the
new Y so I'm going to add 1 to both
sides okay
so that gives us 2 y equals x plus 1
okay then we're going to divide
everything by 2 and you can see that's
what we were getting right here so you
can see this is coming out to y equals
1/2 X plus 1/2 I'm just dividing this by
2 and this by 2 now let's talk about the
graph a little bit so say we graph this
original equation here y equals 2x minus
1 the y-intercept is negative 1 the
slope is 2 so I'm going up 2 over 1 up 2
over 1 up 2 over 1 it looks something
like this right ok now this one here we
have y equals 1/2 X plus 1/2 so we have
the y-intercept of 1/2 we're going up 1
over 2 up 1 over 2 approximately like
that okay so I'm trying to give us a
pretty good decent sketch here so this
is like something like this okay now
what you're going to notice about these
two graphs is that these graphs are the
reflections over this dashed line this
dashed line is the line y equals x
whenever you reflect something over the
line y equals x it's the same thing as
interchanging the x and y coordinates
like we did here in this first example
so that's another way to kind of
identify inverse functions is that
you'll see that they're the reflection
the mirror image over this 45 degree
line the line y equals x ok so now let's
go ahead and do a little bit more
challenging example we've got f of X
equals 1/3 X plus 7 notice the system
this is written in the function notation
the f of X notation so when you see f of
X you can think of that like Y okay and
now we're going to do is we're going to
find the inverse function so we're gonna
do that by energy
changing the X and the y wherever you
see why you're going to put X wherever
you see X you're going to put Y and
we're going to do some more challenging
examples too after this one but just to
show you the process so our goal is to
solve for the new Y we're gonna subtract
7 from both sides so X minus 7 equals
1/3 Y we're going to do the opposite of
multiplying by 1/3 we're gonna divide by
1/3 which is really like multiplying
both sides by 3 and so now you can see
the 1/3 and the 3 cancel and we're
getting y equals 3x minus 21
now you see we started off with this f
of X notation what we're going to do
instead of writing this as Y we're going
to write this as f inverse of X so see
that little minus 1 there F minus 1 that
just means that this function is the
inverse of this function right here so
3x minus 21 is just a notation to
represent that the functions are
inverses so ok so a more challenging
example we're gonna find the inverse of
this one now now what you notice here is
that you know f of X we're gonna
represent that as Y and this is equal to
2x plus 3 over X minus 4 now remember we
said that if we want to find the inverse
we interchange the X and the y well here
we have two x's so what we're going to
do is we're gonna wherever we see X
we're going to replace that with Y so we
actually have two y's now and one X no
problem we still want to isolate that Y
we want to solve for y so what I'm going
to do is I'm going to think of this as a
fraction by putting it over 1
anything divided by 1 is itself right
and then what we're gonna do is we're
gonna cross multiply across the diagonal
ok to get rid of the fraction so this is
just a cross-product so what we have
here is x times y minus 4 equals 2y plus
3 times 1 which is of course itself
anything times 1 I'm going to distribute
the act so that gives us XY minus 4x
right equals 2 y plus 3 and then what
we're going to do is any term that has a
Y in it we want to get on one side
everything else you want to get on the
other side so I'm going to subtract 2y
from both sides so that's XY minus 2y
and I'm going to add the 4x to the other
side so that's going to be 4x plus 3 now
you see these two y's here what we want
to do is we want to factor out the Y ok
that's the that's the trick that's the
key for these types of problems is to
factor out the Y then what you can do
the opposite of multiplying
- - is to divide both sides by X - 2
okay those are going to cancel and now
you can see this is going to be our
inverse function right here so y equals
4x plus 3 over the quantity X minus 2 so
a little bit more challenging example
okay now the next thing we want to talk
about is is the inverse a function so
here's what we have to talk about the
vertical line test VLT and the
horizontal line test HLT right vertical
line tests what we do is we take a
vertical line say for example like this
marker and we go across the graph like
this right basically what we're doing is
we're drawing vertical lines and we're
seeing if it crosses the graph more than
once if it crosses the graph more than
once that means that this you know
equation this graph is not a function it
means for every x value there would be
more than one y value okay this one
passes the vertical line test that means
that this graph is a function but if we
want to find out whether the inverse of
this graph is a function that's when we
use the horizontal line test and so what
we're doing here is we're drawing
horizontal lines like this and we're see
if it crosses the graph more than once
and in this case you can see it's
crossing at two points so that means
that it fails the horizontal line test
that means that the inverse of this
graph is not a function right and
basically what the horizontal line test
is it's a shortcut see the other way to
do this is remember how we talked about
earlier in this video that if we reflect
a graph over the line y equals x we get
the inverse graph right and so if we
reflect this parabola over this line
what you see we're getting is a graph
that looks like this it's actually like
a parabola that's on its side right now
when you look at this graph here you can
see it's failing the vertical line test
for every x value there's two y values
right so for every input you're getting
you know two different outputs that's
not a function but what this horizontal
line test does is it saves us a lot of
time energy effort of having to you know
reflect that graph over the line y
equals x and then do the vertical line
test we can just look at the original
graph and do the horizontal line test
and see if the inverse would be a
function okay so that's an important
concept the next thing we want to talk
about is how do we verify whether
functions are inverses of each other and
how do we prove it
so your teacher will oftentimes ask you
these questions and what you want to do
is you want to do the composition of
functions so what I mean by that is you
want to find out what f of G of X is and
what G of f of X is if you get X for
both of these when you compose the two
functions that proves that the functions
are inverses of each other and I'll try
to explain why it's like this like say
for example you put X into your function
right and that takes you over here right
and then if you put that quantity here
and you put it into the inverse function
you should get back X right because
whatever operations you're doing the
inverse function if it reverses it
should take you back to that initial
input which was X so that's that's the
logic and the thinking behind it but
let's go ahead and do an example here so
half of G of X this top one right here
what we're gonna do is we're going to
take G of X which is 1/2 X plus 1/2
right and we're gonna put that in right
here
now the way functions work is whatever's
in parentheses we put in for X on the
right side of the equation okay so this
is 2 and this is going to be our new
input our new x value our new quantity
that we're substituting in so now you
can see if we distribute we're getting 2
times 1/2 which X which is X 2 times 1/2
which is 1 and 1 minus 1 you can see
those are cancelling and you're getting
ax so that's great now you don't want to
stop there a lot of students will say oh
yeah I proved it I verified it you also
want to do it the other way right so you
want to do G of f of X so here what
we're doing now is we're taking the F
function that's this quantity here and
we're putting it into our G function now
remember the way functions work you take
whatever's in the parentheses here that
that's the input you want to put that in
for X on the right side right so that's
going to be 1/2 plus 1/2 now we're
putting this in okay for X like that so
if we distribute the 1/2 we're getting
1/2 times 2x which is X 1/2 times
negative 1 which is negative 1/2 plus
1/2 now notice those negative 1/2 so
positive and halves are cancelling we're
getting X so you can see that we prove
both F of G of X and G of f of X gave us
X so we reversed out that process we
show that they're undoing one
and that proves or verifies that the do
functions are inverses of each other
so that's an important concept to
understand the next thing we want to
talk about is how to restrict the domain
because sometimes like the graph we had
here this we realize that it was not a
function so the inverse was not a
function so we say well how do we look
at just a portion of that graph so that
the inverse is a function let's talk
about that next okay so we're looking
here at the function f of X equals 2x
squared minus 1
we recognize that this is a parabola see
it's a quadratic x squared the minus 1
is shifting it down 1 the 2 is
stretching the graph making it go up a
little bit faster and make a little bit
narrower but when we look at this graph
remember we talked about earlier how the
horizontal line test tests to see if the
inverse is a function you see how it's
failing that horizontal line test it's
crossing at more than one point so that
means the inverse of this you know
function is this inverse of this graph
is not a function right so what we need
to do or what we're asked to do here is
to restrict the domain so that the
inverse is a function okay meaning we
want it to pass that horizontal line
test okay now what we can do here is
let's go ahead and look at one half of
this graph now it doesn't have to be
half but let's just look at this portion
right here okay this part I'm making a
little bit darker okay this part that's
greater than or equal to zero so X is
greater than or equal to zero and you
can see now it passes the horizontal
line test right so that means that the
inverse of this graph will be a function
so let's look at the domain for a minute
so the domain we said for this part is X
is greater than equal to zero the range
is y is greater than or equal to
negative one okay but when you find the
inverse okay what happens is because
you're switching the X and the y the
domain and the range are actually
switching okay so with our inverse
function the domain is going to be X is
greater than or equal to negative one
and the range is going to be Y is
greater than or equal to zero okay so
they just switch like that but let's go
ahead and find the inverse here so what
we're gonna do is we're going to start
off with y equals two x squared minus
one we're gonna interchange the X and
the y like we did earlier and we're
gonna solve for the new Y so I'm gonna
add one to both sides right so that's X
plus one equals two Y squared I'm gonna
divide both sides by two right
and then so now we have y squared equals
x plus 1 over 2 I just flipped the
equation I'm gonna take the square root
but remember when you take the square
root how many answers do you get to
write plus or minus so this is gonna be
a plus or minus the square root of x
plus 1 over 2 now this is interesting if
you graph this on your graphing Tucket
or by hand what you would get is you
would get well let me see if I can
explain basically what you would get is
you would get this and you would get
this ok you have to actually graph it in
two parts you have to graph y equals
plus the square root of x plus 1 over 2
and y equals negative square root of x
plus 1 over 2 the positive part is this
part right here this top part okay and
you can see that if you reflect just
this part over here over the line y
equals x you're gonna get a graph that
looks approximately like that ok and so
if you were to reflect this part over
the line y equals x then you would get
the other half of the parabola that's
this part here ok so depending on how
you're restricting the domain if you're
looking at you know this right half
you're going to be looking at this part
of the graph which is this one here y
equals positive square root of x plus 1
over 2 if you're looking at where X is
less than or equal to 0 then we'd be
looking at y equals negative square root
of x plus 1 over 2 so this is an
important concept to understand so now
your teacher will ask you to restrict
the domain and again you want to kind of
pay attention to we know what path
you're looking at so when you go to
solve for the inverse you take the
proper water whether it's a positive one
or the negative one so this is a design
this video to be a complete guide to
just understanding you know what
inverses are all about how to find
inverses you know how to verify they're
inverses how to restrict the domain etc
if you liked this video give me a thumbs
up on the video to let me know or put a
comment in the comments below if you
have additional questions or things you
want to ask about and a lot of times
when students are reading the comments
oftentimes they'll answer those
questions before even I can get to them
so help one another out in that comment
section below and let me know what you
thought of the video and I look forward
to helping you in the future videos I'll
talk to you soon